hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from the fide women's
candidates tournament it is humpicanero
of India versus Anna music of Ukraine
and it is uh quite quite a brutal game
24 moves uh in in modern chess that can
be considered a miniature it's uh it's a
very very uh top level game up to a
certain point where a slight inaccuracy
is made that leads to uh uh a complete
deterioration of one's position you'll
see what I mean by this it's uh it's
really a wonderful game and they are of
course battling it out for the right and
privilege to challenge the reigning
world Women's Champion Jew engine uh
these are the d8 participants
and Alexandra costenuk we have the pool
a and the pool B and then they they mix
it up so let's dive straight into it
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
D4 we have Ponta D5 C4 going for the
Queen's Gambit and the D captures and C4
Anna accepts the Gambit Knight to F3
with Knight to F6 and now Pawn the E3
ready to recollect the opponent C4 upon
the E6 and now just Bishop captures and
C4 we have Pawn to C5 and here castles
we have Pawn to A6 and none are the
first sort of an offbeat move of the
game is spawned to B3 only the sixth
most popular continuation uh aimed at
obviously confusing um uh Anna music and
trying to get the most out of the
position so here we have Knight B to D7
and now uh you would expect something
like Bishop to B2 or just continuing
development but this should be back to
E2 so this is now already very very
weird it has been attempted a few times
uh but it will be very very strange if
Anna was actually ready for this so here
Pawn to B6 preparing to Finca to the
bishop and now Knight the E5 offering a
trade of knights but also ready to play
Bishop to F3 to go after the rook and A8
with Bishop to B7 you could also trade
if you go Knight captures for example
Pawn captures n9d5 this is also I have a
very nice for black but in the game we
have the chapter B7 uh Bishop to F3
offering a trade of Bishops and now
there are a few games where that reach
this possession for example Harry
kadrona Valley had this against
kanimbalaliva in this year's fide
women's Olympiad where Knight the D5 was
played in that game ended in a draw and
also Queen to C7 is a known movie also
this year was played in the shardock
Masters between American and Manuel
Petrosian where American won the game
after Queen to C7 was played by by
petrozian but here we have Bishop
captures on F3 by muzicook and it is now
as of move 10 that we have a completely
new game so let's see what happens Queen
captures an F3 with Bishop to D6 putting
pressure on the Knight and not Knight
captures on D7 this force is uh uh on at
uh well I put the knights to a to a less
optimal Square you can't capture with
the queen because the rook and A8 hangs
so Knight captures on D7 okay it's
nothing special for white Bishop to A3
uh putting the bishop on on this long
diagonal and queen to B8 now with tempo
as the H2 Pawn is hanging so D captures
on C5 and now you're not in time to
capture on H2 because you know from your
own games when you capture an H2 white
just wants to play G3 and trap your
Bishop then you have to play something
you have to move the bishop back so that
doesn't happen and then already white
has a pass Pawn on C6 so you don't want
this to happen so okay Knight captures
on C5 Queen to C6 check and now King to
E7 and this is the best way to play of
course you cannot block this or move
anything if you move the Knight then the
bishop just hangs so King the E7
uh Anna will now not be castling in a in
a traditional fashion but uh Rook the C8
is coming then you can put the king and
f8 the G8 and you can sort of
artificially Castle later on so it's not
a big deal Knight the D2 continuing
development also getting ready to add
more pressure yeah to Black's position
we have rooked the C8 attacking the
queen and the queen back to F3 and now
okay the pawn on H2 is now hanging it's
a free Pawn so we might as well capture
it Bishop captures an H2 King to H1 and
now comes uh the moment where uh Anna
takes a sort of a wrong turn she plays
Bishop back to D6 which is a move anyone
would play you would expect this to
happen uh you do not want the slide
Square this dark Square Bishop um uh
sort of x-raying your king so it makes
sense to bring it back to D6 best would
be to put it back to E5 uh point being
that now if let's say rotate the C1 you
go after the Knight now you just start
running with the King and if Knight E4
adding more pressure to the Knight here
you again run and you you give back the
pawn and you you hide your king to
safety and the game continues something
like captures captures the white wins
the pawn back and okay the game
continues uh not nothing much for either
side uh you know chances for both sides
basically but okay after King H1 Bishop
to D6 was played and this allows this a
very very beautiful Knight to C4 move
and now the problem is uh there's too
much pressure uh how do you how do you
get out of this point is if you play
something like B5 okay you you think you
might be able to trade here let's say
Knight captures Queen captures there's a
roket to C1 and okay you have the Knight
defended by the rook and by the queen
but the other Rook is coming to D1 and
if we're okay to B8 and also notice that
if white starts capturing here then the
rook and A8 will be hanging so you have
to play something like Rook 8 to B8 now
Rook have to D1 attacks the queen and if
Queen E5 you still have to defend the
Knight now Queen G4 with ideas of Queen
B4 and also on to F4 and now if you try
to unpin it seems like there's an
there's a chance you might be able to
pull it off just Queen before now if the
Knight moves you just get checkmated if
the Knight doesn't the move you just win
the night
and if you play A5 you can just play
even Queen captures on A5 they're still
not all that much uh for black to do if
Knights the E4 just King G1 you defend
the pawn and you don't really care uh
you've just won another Pawn a black can
never move an inch with the King and
it's just completely winning for white
so that's the problem it's uh how do you
how do you untangle here how do you get
the king to G8 without white doing
anything uh so okay King to f8 is is a
move that Anna chooses King the E8 is
the is the only mood that's possible
here white would still have a slight
Edge but King the E8 keeps her in the
game but after King to f8 which is
closer to the G8 Square it is now that
white is completely winning and it's
just beautiful how yeah how humpy does
it you can play Rook 8 D1 or Rook after
D1 it doesn't matter but the Rook must
come to D1 so here look at this rotate
the D1 and now how do you defend this
what do you play here uh it's uh the
problem is okay the the bishop is now
hanging if you move the bishop let's say
you play Bishop E5 which we said was a
better Square than Bishop to D6 not in
this position though because now Rook to
D7 and look at this the Knight cannot
move of course so Checkmate is being
threatened and once you block Checkmate
look at this Rook B7 it wins the queen
ah absolutely incredible uh so there's
that so you can't do that so now that
the bishop is saying Bishop to E7 is
played by Anna but now again the
position is completely winning but there
is only one line and it's a very very
specific line that you have to calculate
uh that wins the game for humpy so feel
free to pause the video and win the game
for whom B while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations as this is not a
simple one to calculate and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is best shop captures on C5 the point is
that is a free night there on C5 and you
can just capture it in the black cannot
recapture or rather black must recap for
about whatever black recapters with uh
loses the game for her so the problem is
now okay big captures on C5 was played
in the game uh so also congratulations
to everyone who spotted this it's not
really the first move you look at it's a
capture I know but it's you know it's
not something that we expected that will
solve all of our problems uh point is
that if Bishop captures okay the bishop
now again move from E7 and now Rook D7
is winning again you have to block
Checkmate and then this wins the queen
uh all over so after uh this move you
can play Rook captures on C5 another
possibility but now look at this Knight
captures on B6 again there's the problem
of the hanging rook and A8 if Queen
captures just Queen captures on A8 so
row K7 can be played now Knight to D7
check with a monster Fork here a forking
the king the queen and the Rook on C5
and now after Rook captures on D7 just a
rook captures on D7 and you're up the
exchange uh uh you know it's uh
completely winning uh possession just
Queen B7 you don't really care uh
everything is winning here uh so Anna
tried B captures on C5 and now Rook to
D7 again a beautiful beautiful move uh
preparing Knight to D6 and there's just
no good way to stop this Rook to A7 was
played but the other moves don't help
Anna either here we have Knight to D6
and again what do you play uh mate is
being threatened Knight and queen are
now attacking the F7 Pawn if Bishop
captures then rook and queen get the job
done then again Queen captures on F7 uh
what can you play here Queen captures on
D6 was played by Anna it was one final
attempt at giving up the queen for some
material but of course uh humpy doesn't
go for the queen she just plays a rook
captures on A7 and it was in this
position on move 24 that Anna music
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here now once you play
anything it doesn't really matter you're
just down too much material D just Queen
B7 you will win the A6 spawn
uh nothing nothing to try there
and if you're wondering why not uh
capture the queen here instead of The
Rook well then okay uh I mean you have
the bishop and The Rook now for a queen
you have the seep on the a pawn it's not
as clear white will probably win this in
the long run but it will be a very long
long uh game here just through captors
on A7 and now you just resign uh so yeah
uh really uh uh uh nicely played by by
humping uh I don't know what part of the
game was uh preparation and what was
found at the board but uh okay she did
out prepare Anna definitely in this one
but finding all of this like Rook 81
just bishop p7 and now Bishop captures I
mean absolutely absolutely stunning but
even after King the E8 which is the only
move that saves the game for Anna sort
of it's still a terrible position for
black uh I mean it's hard to say if if
she would be able to to get out of this
one so really really interesting line if
you if you guys played uh the Queen's
Gambit if your Gambit gets accepted a
lot you can try this idea starting with
this Pawn to B3 and the bishop back to
E2 weird stuff but it worked like a
charm for her uh so yeah uh that's the
game I hope you guys enjoyed it really
really a nice one thank you thank you
for suggesting it uh we'll see what
happens uh in the other games I will try
to simultaneously cover both the world
Fisher random Champion Japan the women's
candidates tournament so I will see how
it goes uh I would like to thank Stephen
Pryor as the shadow subramanian John
shirtleff
and Jeff Morrow for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the women's
candidates continuing the coverage of
the world Fisher random championship and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day